foreign
members of the deer family include elk
and reindeer and moose and we think of
them as lovable sort of characters you
know like Bambi springing along and
Rudolph leading Santa's sleigh and then
there's Bullwinkle a moose but what are
the dangers that wild deer actually pose
when they come into our neighborhoods
[Music]
that's going to be a complicated
Insurance claim okay
I like how that lady's going back for a
handbag
[Music]
oh the poor thing
the deer is clearly terrified in this
situation that big plate glass window
might have had Reflections and this
looks like to be some Shrubbery on the
other side the deer might have thought
with the reflection of green that this
was actually an Escape Route and it
found itself in a hairdressing Salon
instead
thank you
[Music]
but what's it doing in a town in broad
daylight anyway well we keep on building
them where the animals are living and on
top of that we create lovely Gardens
right that have beautiful grasses and
lots of trees coming down so the deer
like to forage and graze on all of these
things and are attracted into our towns
or it just wanted a crew cut
I'm headed in
this moose Trail
okay I spotted uh three bowls two were
shedded and one still had both sides
[Music]
I was flying my drone and he took
himself and shook both antlers off wow
what an amazing thing to actually
capture that sort of didn't realize that
it would happen so seamlessly but I
suppose that's logical what's actually
happening is their testosterone drops it
really bottoms out and that weakens the
calcium that joins the antlers onto the
skull and essentially one day when it's
weak enough they get up shake and
they're antlers pop off
and this is one of the differences right
between antlers and horns horns are bony
protrusions that do not regrow and are
found on bovines and antlers are these
immensely beautiful intricate bony
protrusions that regrow every season and
are covered in velvet well at least
initially are covered in velvet and what
it actually does is helps blood supply
go all the way up through the antler and
they can grow really fast as much as 20
centimeters in nine days
that's a growth spurt
scared and trampling you
it's not my mousse but it's a goddamn
wild animal get the away from it
good advice
you idiots
[Music]
you wish it would hit me right now
gone because idiots
and he fell straight over yeah get it
get him get him I shouldn't be mean and
cynical but I really can't help it have
you guys not watched any of the previous
videos do not interfere with wild
animals
apparently in Alaska more people are
injured due to Moose incidents than bare
incidents and I think in part that's due
to the fact that people aren't initially
scared of moose so they act like idiots
moose uh in general not aggressive
towards humans they really don't want
that much to do with us but they will
get protective in this case protecting
itself but they also might be trying to
protect their young get
someone once said that you should treat
all moose as if they're serial killers
with a loaded gun Don't Go Near him
who's this coming along
look at that creature
we've got one heck of a rack is it
appropriate to talk about someone's rack
like that
a big Cruiser
it's bigger than that car
s are the largest members of the deer
family they can weigh up to 680
kilograms they grow up to like two
meters tall
really good video to see the Bell it's
like this sort of fold of skin that
hangs below the moose's chin and makes
them extra handsome now he's picking up
a little speed and going for a walk they
live in incredibly cold environments the
northern part of North America and right
across through Europe and Russia as well
and one of the ways which they cope with
the cold is actually by having hair that
is hollow like each individual strand of
hair is hollow and that creates a buffer
sort of like they were wearing a puffer
jacket
yeah
that sounds
oh
I know one of them just lost his mobile
phone
[Music]
so what you're seeing is one of the
males trying to get an uphill Advantage
trying to make himself bigger so that
the one who's a little bit down the
slope has a disadvantage in the fighting
situation
I don't know where they're jumping into
the Ute thing comes in though that's
just weird
[Music]
now they're just confused they're like
oh wait this is a bit unusual
male moose have a rutting season it goes
from September to October roughly
they'll be asserting themselves over all
the other males in the area and on top
of that the forehead skin gets thicker
this is to you know so they don't get
stabbed by someone else's antler and
their neck muscles get something like
two times thicker than they normally are
it's like they turn into gym Bros like
overnight just all the testosterone they
have no chill no chill at all in the
running season
look at that big Cruiser from the
massive size to their impressive
headwear and even their sort of grumpy
demeanor it's pretty clear that a moose
on the loose is a dangerous thing
[Music]